ce
bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'actu
sur tv fil 78 nouvelle édition du
journal de la rédaction nous débutons ce
11 février par la journée de mobilité
2.0 qui se tenait à satory une journée
autour de la stratégie pour développer
les modes de déplacements intelligents
pas encore de voiture volante mais
bientôt des véhicules 100% automatisé
est connecté le ministre des transports
frédéric cuvillier était présent ce
matin
quels transports intelligents pour
demain le thème d'une rencontre proposé
ce mardi sur le plateau de satory à
versailles et le lieu n'est pas un
hasard puisque c'est ici que sera
prochainement créé l'institut vd comme
comme véhicule décarboné communicants et
mobilité une fondation partenariale de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
également financé par le conseil général
dd com va être dotée de moyens
financiers considérables 330 millions
sur neuf ans les investissements
d'avenir y apporte 54 millions les
industries en apporte 119 le conseil
général apporte un bref tout le monde
s'est mis ensemble pour constituer un
centre de recherche technique de
d'industrialisation qui réunit toute
l'industrie
vous avez en france c'est pas si facile
que ça à faire travailler les gens
ensemble les véhicules de demain qu'il
soit électrique connecté ou automatisés
un enjeu majeur comme l'a expliqué le
ministre des transports venus assister
ses rangs nous avons la chance d'avoir
des gens de grand talent avec des
chercheurs des découvreurs avec des
industriels avec
véritablement une passion des gens
passionnés et qui croient à leur
capacité collective à relever des défis
une société nouvelle et bien c'est à la
fois réconfortant et ça doit donner
confiance en l'avenir vers notre
capacité parce que c'est le cas d'être
la france leader mondial et sur la
mobilité intelligente la france a pour
vocation d'être leader mondial
actuellement la filière des transports
intelligents représentent 4,5 milliards
d'euros avec 500 à un millier
d'entreprises concernées sur toutes les
start up soit 45 mille emplois directs
et claire cambier reviendra pour la
rédaction sur ce déplacement du ministre
et ce rendez-vous de la mobilité 2.0
dans le prochain numéro de fil échos ce
jeudi dès 18h30 en direct ailes de la
voiture du futur à la maison du futur du
27 juin au 14 juillet la ville de
versailles accueille le solar decathlon
en rendez vous international a lancé en
2002 par le département de l'énergie des
états-unis qui se déroule donc tous les
deux ans en europe avec ce défi
concevoir et construire une maison
solaire autonome en énergie nous allons
parler sur ce plateau avec le directeur
de la compétition dans un instant on
écoute déjà à la ministre du logement
cécile duflot nous parler de ce choix de
la ville de versailles pour recevoir
l'événement
c'est un formidable clin d'oeil
historique d'ailleurs d'abord je pense
et ensuite je partage beaucoup de ce
qu'a dit le député-maire sur le fait que
l'innovation peut croiser le patrimoine
et versailles c'est le fleuron un des
fleurons du patrimoine français c'est
toute une histoire et c'est aussi
l'avenir et donc c'est faire renaître un
des endroits du parc dessiné par le
nôtre il ya quatre siècles
à l'occasion du solar decathlon je
trouve que c'est un très bon signe
bonsoir pascal rollet est donc le
directeur du solar decathlon europe 2014
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
viens d'entendre cécile duflot la
ministre en novembre dernier lors de la
présentation officielle de ces vingt
projets qui vont participer à
l'événement lors de ce rendez-vous de
présentation elle disait également que
le succès n'était possible que si
l'ensemble des acteurs répondait présent
universitaire bien évidemment puisqu'il
participe à l'élaboration de ces projets
mais aussi les artisans qui vont ensuite
réalisé en dessous de tout ces maquettes
en grandeur grandeur nature et puis par
la suite se les appliquer dans la vie de
tous les jours
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est en bonne
voie tout le monde va dans le même sens
vous avez réussi à fédérer en france
autour de ce projet de solar decathlon
là comme le disait le ministre des
transports c'est pas facile de faire
travailler les gens ensemble en france
au mode la mobilité au teil de la
mobilité remet effectivement c'est un
des enjeux énormes du solar decathlon
c'est de faire travailler ensemble
citect ingénieurs constructeurs
développeurs et industriels et ceux du
projet permet de le faire effectivement
et nous sommes donc on passe de réussir
ce pari
les partenaires sont nombreux sur un
événement comme le solar decathlon les
partenaires les gros partenaires
industriels sont
sont nombreux et son vie viennent nous
rejoindre notamment des gens comme
schneider electric total bouygues ou une
construction on est méritée on va la
science de ces enjeux oui parce que
c'est un essai leur marché de l'avenir
le logement et la construction de la
ville et pour eux le domaine de
débouchés absolument et non on va
revenir sur l'événement en lui-même mais
déjà pour bien préciser le solar
decathlon c'est une compétition il ya
une vingtaine d' équipes qui
s'affrontent avec des projets de maison
du futur une maison solaire autonome en
énergie
quels sont les critères comment se passe
la compétition mais c'est un décathlon
donc ça rien à voir avec la marque
espoirs français ce n'est pas partenaire
c'est donc dix épreuves et on juge de
l'architecturé de l'ingénierie de
l'efficacité énergétique de la balance
électrique mais aussi comme c'est une
maison d'un du maintien de conditions de
confort à l'intérieur du fonctionnement
de la maison on fait des lessives on
fait sécher du linge ont fait des repas
et on accueille des gens à l'intérieur
et puis comme il s'agit aussi de parler
au grand public et bien la communication
et la manière dont on diffuse des
connaissances scientifiques à ce sujet
et noté et puis évidemment l'innovation
est globalement sur comme critère
transversale la soutenabilité c'est à
dire le comment les projets s'inscrivent
dans une politique et une stratégie de
développement durable
le public pourra découvrir tout ça
puisque c'est ouvert au public et que
chacun pourra à versailles assister et
déjà voir se construire ces différentes
maisons autonomes appelé peut-être à
demain constitué l'essentiel de
l'habitat à travers à travers le monde
pourquoi pas les équipes sont composées
de chercheurs de professionnels qui
travaillent sur tous ces dossiers maison
les équipes sont composées d'étudiants
pour la plupart des étudiants plutôt au
niveau master
encadré aussi par des doctorants qui en
est le sujet spécifique et puis par des
enseignants chercheurs mais aussi et
c'est là une grande importance et
nouveauté de ce genre de formation et
d'expérience avec des industriels qui
sont eux mêmes partenaires de chaque
équipe et qu'ils vont la construire sa
maison et les étudiants conçoivent et
construisent alors pour les
constructions les parties de
construction peut-être un peu spécifique
est en droit de faire appel à des
entrepreneurs spécialisés mais au moins
80% de la maison doit être construite
par les étudiants et donc c'est aussi
bien exercice de construction et de
communication que de planification et de
d'immenses logistique parce qu'on voit
les maquettes qui ont été exposés
récemment d'ailleurs à l'hôtel de ville
de versailles
ensuite ça va véritablement sortir de
terrain ça va pas rester à l'échelle de
maquettes quel est l'enjeu pour la
france d'accueillir ce rendez vous
rendez vous à une dizaine d'années un
déjà mais il a été lancé aux états unis
maintenant c'est aussi en europe tous
les tous les deux ans l'enjeu pour la
france c'est 2 de briller et de
s'imposer sur ce secteur encore en
devient l'enjeu pour la france est de
montrer la vitrine de son savoir faire
dans le domaine de la ville durable
elle a des atouts très importants dans
ce domaine là
de faire la liaison avec les questions
de la mobilité aussi est de montrer ce
que les inventeurs les ingénieurs les
architectes français sont capables de
faire dans ce domaine mais c'est aussi
beaucoup plus largement l'occasion de
créer une communauté scientifique
internationale
lorsque le développement durable ça se
réussit pas à quelques maisons
exceptionnel ça se réussit dans la masse
avec le grand nombre la france a un
savoir faire dans ce domaine justement
de développement des nouvelles énergies
de maison solaire autonome 100%
on le sait l'industrie du bâtiment a
quelques difficultés en france avec une
période économique difficile ça peut
permettre de relancer de voir de
nouvelles perspectives
absolument la france était pionnière
dans les années 70 dans le domaine du
photovoltaïque
et puis suite à l' eau chaude pétroliers
au choix politique d'orientation que
nous avons fait au niveau de l'énergie
on a un peu laissé tomber ce domaine là
ils sont plutôt les américains les
allemands les japonais qui ont beaucoup
travaillé avancé et puis voilà on
découvre la nécessité absolue de
travailler sur les énergies
renouvelables et
il ya un vrai marché de savoir faire de
l'industrie a développé à partir de là
une nouvelle économie
une économie verte qui peut se mettre en
place une quinzaine de nationalités
participent au solar decathlon sur la
vingtaine d'équipés quels sont les quels
sont les universités qui les
universitaires qui vont représenter la
france cette année alors les équipes
françaises sont une équipe rassemblée
autour de l'école d'architecturé de
nantes et l'école centrale et du site de
l'ensemble atlanbois qui est des gens
qui consultent en bois du côté
atlantique ça s'appelle atlantic
challenge
et puis la deuxième équipe française est
groupé autour de l'école d'architecturé
de paris malaquais avec l'école spéciale
des travaux publics et tout un ensemble
de chercheurs qui sont sur paris tech et
en 2002 c'était une équipe française qui
l'avait emporté sur l'art des quatre
voilà c'est donc une équipe rhône-alpes
aux tournées d ecône architecture de
grenoble et de lyon qui avait remporté
avec un projet qui s'appelait canopée à
qui était un projet de tour en milieu
urbain dense et demi
tours écologique soit le même succès aux
équipes françaises qui sont engagés pour
le solar decathlon de 2014 qui se
déroulera en france cette année et donc
à versailles
les maquettes et projets qui sont
développés ensuite sont commercialisés
est-ce qu'ils sont développés est ce
qu'il ya une viabilité ensuite la
plupart de ces projets sont des projets
de recherche qui sont au stade
développement on va dire prototype et
qui ont pour objectif de devenir
effectivement des modèles pour la
production en grande masse et pour la
diffusion auprès du grand public
on est au stade on va dire concept car
ce stade là et toutes les choses qui
sont testés notamment au niveau de
l'innovation vont petit à petit percolé
dans le dans l'habitat normale dans
l'habitat de production en grande masse
ceci dit ça prend du temps
ces prototypes pour la plupart tous
rapatriés dans leurs universités sur les
campus comme objet de recherche comme
démonstrateur
certaines ont été vendus à des
particuliers c'est une parfois certaines
équipes ont choisi ce mode de
financement
mais pour la plupart c'est un objet
d'étude qui donnera lieu à une deuxième
génération souvent même à une troisième
avant de diffuser dans le l'habitat
générale ont toutes dernières questions
très rapidement il ya un enjeu aussi
pour le bassin local vous êtes beaucoup
d'implication des changes avec
l'université par exemple l'école
d'architecturé
il ya une vraie devrait retomber sur le
bassin aussi oui et c'est très important
qu'on soit justement
en relation très forte avec deux bassins
industriels la région et des yvelines et
de autour de versailles l'école
d'architecturé de versailles joue un
rôle très important dans l'opération
puisqu'elle soutient l'équipe
d'organisation
ce qui m'a fournir beaucoup des
volontaires qui vont aider à encadrer et
à guider le public et à le
présenter les maisons et même assuré
globalement le fonctionnement de la cité
du soleil donc c'est comme ça que
s'appelle ce lieu où on va accueillir
les 20 prototypes et les écoles
d'ingénieurs de la région et tous les
mets centre de recherche de saclay
autour de saclay sont impliqués des
industrielles comme air liquide qui sont
juste à côté ont justement vu là une
manière de faire une vitrine sur
d'autres sources d'énergie comme
l'hydrogène que l'on montrera au moment
du solar decathlon
on aura bien évidemment l'occasion d'en
reparler sur cette antenne merci pascal
rollet d'être vu venu sur ce plateau je
donne les dates de ce solar decathlon à
versailles à partir du 27 juin il ya un
site internet aussi si vous voulez
toutes les informations merci à vous si
culture à présent 24 heures pour
découvrir l'afrique aux clayes-sous-bois
ce week end les associations proposaient
a ainsi des stages de percussions de
confection de masques également olivier
maniscalco et j'en attends ville
vingt-quatre heures au rythme de
l'afrique
à l'initiative de l'association donc
qu'est mousseau basée aux
clayes-sous-bois une journée d'animation
était organisée samedi à l'école henri
cuq stage de percussions et de danse
ateliers créatifs ou dégustation de
spécialités africaines
plus de 150 personnes ont participé à
l'événement un événement dont les
bénéfices serviront au financement d'un
centre socioculturel avec éco village de
la banlieue d'abidjan laon provisionnent
effectivement au fur et à mesure pour
pouvoir participer à ce projet l'école
la base c'est payant 1
donc il ya des enfants qui n'ont pas la
chance d'aller à l'école toutes les
personnes qui sont là donc les
percussionnistes danseurs à toutes les
personnes pour les activités créatives
des enfants en fait sont venus
bénévolement donc tout ça dans le but de
récolter un maximum d'argent
des fonds qui vont permettre d'apprendre
à lire et à écrire aux enfants des
quartiers défavorisés mais aussi à
développer leur culture notamment par la
pratique des danses traditionnelles des
danses que le public a eu l'occasion de
découvrir durant ces 24 heures africaine
tout ce qu'on vient de faire un pas qui
viendront dès la guinée du mali et du
burkina
voilà mais tu peux le retrouver aussi au
nom de la côte d'ivoire joue en valeur
que ça soit funérailles brad m on va là
on s'est peut-être comme ça en afrique
en voilà ça petit entier je vais dire à
toutes les silhouettes
1300 euros ont été récoltés lors de
cette manifestation aux clayes-sous-bois
autre ambiance on termine ce journal
avec des images du carnaval des
étudiants en médecine de l'université de
versailles saint quentin ils ont défilé
dans les rues de guyancourt et de
montigny le bretonneux avant d'aller
perturber dans une bonne ambiance les
cours en amphithéâtre dans d autres
filières
un moment festif qui permet de mettre de
côté les inquiétudes sur le financement
de l'établissement
une pétition demandant un soutien accru
de l'état en matière de dotation et de
l'emploi est d'ailleurs toujours
accessible sur internet
elle a totalisé en quelques mois plus de
5500 et signature lecture revient demain
18h toujours en direct sur tes défilent
ce mardi soir vous avez rendez vous avec
catherine gillet tôt pour municipales
2014 le magazine l'essentiel de la
campagne dans les yvelines
excellente soit